Vince, I, uh,
I have that quarterly analysis
that you asked for.
I had a quarter
of these nuts on your chin.
[clears throat]
Right.
It's just that
I wanted to review
some of these numbers
with you.
It seems like
our earnings are low
against
our original projections.
These nuts were low
against your chin.
You know, Vince,
if you ever need
to talk to me about something,
I'm more than happy
to listen.
These nuts would be more than
happy to rest against your chin.
[sighs]
Hey, look, you've been doing
this for about a week now,
and it was kind of funny
at first.
These nuts were kind of funny
against your chin.
Vince,
I'm worried about you.
I was worried
about these nuts on your chin.
Vince, seriously.
[sighs]
[whispering]
These nuts were seriously
on your chin.
Mr. Graham, I just got a call
from St. Mary's Hospital,
and your parents
were in a serious car accident.
I'm so sorry,
but your mother is dead,
and your father
is on life support.
These nuts were supporting
life on your chin.
Oh, my God.
- Sorry, Amber.
[door closes]
Vince, you got to stop it.
Your mother
just passed away.
These nuts
passed away on your chin.
No, they didn't.
They didn't.
Vince, listen,
you got to leave here right now
and go be with your dad.
This could be the last time
that you get to see him.
I get to see my nuts on your--
God damn it, Vincent.
Your father might be dying.
These nuts might be
dying on your chin.
God damn it, Vince!
Snap the fuck out of it!
Your mother is dead.
Right.
You're right.
- You okay?
- I'm okay.
You--you're back.
[whispering]
I don't know what came over me.
- It's all right.
- It was so good.
It was--it just--
It worked in every situation,
and then it was--
I know. I know.
And it was always--
it was just so funny.
Well, it wasn't--
it wasn't that funny.
It was funny.
It really wasn't
that funny, Vince.
It was...
really funny.
I would not go so far as to
say it was really funny, Vince.
It was funny.
But it wasn't.
It was.
It wasn't.
Agree to disagree.
- It was funny.
- Okay.
- One more time.
I'm just gonna go on record
as saying it wasn't really
that funny.
I'm gonna go see my dad.
It was funny.
It wasn't that funny.
[sweeping orchestration]
♪ ♪
Dad.
[breathing heavily]
Stay with me.
Dad, I love you.
[monitor beeping]
And I love...
These nuts
on your chin.
[flatline]
[dad's voice]
These nuts on your chin.
[sobbing, wailing]